[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 30 novembre
voici les titres
la cérémonie a débuté il ya quelques
minutes joséphine baker fait son entrée
au panthéon celle qui fut meneuse de
revue mais aussi résistantes à un temps
résider au vésinet et ce soir une classe
de collégiens yvelinois assistent à
l'événement à paris interview à suivre
les adhérents les républicains bat à
partir de demain pour désigner leur
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
course notamment eric ciotti le député
des alpes-maritimes était à versailles
ce lundi pour présenter son programme au
militant et puis vous connaissiez sans
doute le nologie mais avez vous déjà
entendu parler de l'eau les eaux logis
autrement dit l'étude de l'huile d'olive
cécile cros est une spécialiste qui vit
entre les yvelines et la catalogne son
portrait à la fin de cette édition
face à la cinquième vague de kovy 19le
vaccinodromes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines installé au
vélodrome nationale pourrait augmenter
de nouveau sa vaccination quid des
événements sportifs qui devait se
dérouler sur place dans les prochaines
semaines on en parle tout à l'heure
[Musique]
mais direction tout de suite paris avec
ses images en direct la cérémonie de
porter haut nil à sion de joséphine
baker a débuté depuis quelques minutes
elle est la sixième femme à faire son
entrée au cénacle la première femme
noire est la première artiste de scène à
y rentrer le cercueil a remonté déjà
vous le voyez est la rue soufflot porté
par six aviateurs de l'armée de l'air
dont elle ait été membre il ne contient
pas ça des poules qui restera en est là
à monaco mais des poignées de terre venu
de lieux emblématiques de sa vie
notamment de saint louis dans le
missouri aux états unis où la franco
américaine est née en 1906 avant de
prendre la nationalité française en 1937
célèbre meneuse de revue elle était
aussi une résistante pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale elle a caché des armes
et des résistants collecter des
informations joséphine baker a été
honorée d'ailleurs de la médaille de la
résistance de la croisière et de la
légion d'honneur celle qui s'est éteinte
en 1975 est enfin la maman de la tribu
arc en ciel ses 12 enfants qu'elle a
adoptés une femme aux mille vies qui a
vécu au vésinet là était la propriétaire
de la villa beauchesne pendant près de
20 ans écoutez la vice présidente de la
société d'histoire du vésinet
joséphine baker et un parcours très très
particulier un on sait que c'est une
petite fille qui a été maltraité dans
son enfance qui étaient pauvres elle
arrive en france en 1925 26 dans la
revue et là on commence à la
connaître mais ensuite elle va très vite
trouver une villa originaire qui sera
pour elle un havre de paix elle sera là
pour se reposer pour cultiver ses fleurs
ses légumes et avoir tous les animaux
qu'elle voulait avoir donc elle a des
chiens des chats singes
canards poulets et une guéparde qu'il
est offerte par le directeur du casino
messieurs barna mais qui sera aussi sur
scène avec elle et donc avec 7,7 guespin
devant elle va se promener comme si elle
avait un chien et et saviez pas un débat
un jour elle va s'échapper au vésinet et
ça va terroriser tous les habitants mais
heureusement rien de grave
et donc cette panthéonisation à votre
avis sa récompense en quelque sorte ses
mille vies c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
qu'ils avaient qu'elle mérite à votre
avis est entré c'est parce qu'elle était
une artiste multifacettes mais qui a eu
aussi une ville résistante oui tout à
fait qu'elle a combattu le racisme
aussi la ségrégation quand elle allait
aux états unis en tournée à la corrèze
subi
des mauvaises mais moins mauvais accueil
et donc en 1963 elle fera une marche sur
washington avec le pasteur martin luther
king elle sera la seule femme a fait un
discours ce jour la main pour le droit
des hommes et contre le racisme et les
pousses de martin luther king lorsque
sur lui disparaît lui proposera de de le
remplacer
mais joséphine aurait elle a déjà ses 12
enfants pratiquement 12 est vraiment
elle ne peut pas mais je pense que si
elle n'avait pas eu tous ces enfants
milandes elle aurait continué le combat
au vésinet life permis enfants de partir
en vacances elle faisait la distribution
des prix ni les arbres de noël alors
acheter des bonbons des actions enfin
elle et elle avait le coeur sur la main
c'est une femme formidable
déjà dans six villes y avec tout ce
qu'elle a fait durant la guerre aussi
donc elle mérite très largement de
rentrer au penty
joséphine baker on le disait habité
pendant près de 20 ans dans la villa
beauchesne au vésinet est une étape
importante de la vie est de l'artiste
aux mille facettes retour sur sa vie sa
vie de résistante notamment avec mélanie
poké
[Musique]
on
et
e
mon dieu
[Musique]
et
dieu amour
mon pays
et vendus
non
[Musique]
cérémonie de panthéonisation de
joséphine baker vous le voyez sur ces
images qui se poursuit en ce moment à
paris avec un cortège qui a d'ores et
déjà remontée est la rue soufflot le
cortège importer ce cercueil qui est
porté par six aviateurs à remonter cette
rue soufflot on rappelle que joséphine
baker sera la 81e personnes à rentrer
dans ce panthéon sixième femme dans
l'histoire et première femme noire à
faire son entrée dans le cénacle et dans
cette cérémonie est présente notamment
la députée des yvelines marie lebey
qu'elle accompagne ce soir une classe de
collégiens yvelinois écouter cet
entretien enregistré à la mi-journée
[Musique]
et je suis avec marie lebègue bonjour
député la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription des yvelines vous êtes
ce soir à cette cérémonie d'entrer au
panthéon de joséphine baker et vous
accompagnez une classe de 3e du collège
sainte-thérèse de oui on va en parler
dans un instant joséphine baker c'est la
sixième femme à entrer au panthéon la
première femme noire à entrer dans ce
cénacle pourquoi mairie tel cet hommage
de la nation
s'est achevé dimanche une femme qui
s'est énormément engagés à la fois pour
des grandes causes la lutte contre le
racisme
l'égal accès aux droits qui s'est aussi
engagée aux côtés de notre pays dans la
seconde guerre mondiale dans la
résistance en tant que aviateurs et puis
enfin c'est une artiste et je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'une une
artiste rentrer au panthéon et c'est
aussi la reconnaissance finalement de
cette carrière artistique qu'est là
qu'elle a su mener est engagée et qui
nous ont permis une fine et de mener les
combats pour lesquels elle s'est battue
elle est effectivement meneuse de revue
résistante pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale elle a d'ailleurs reçu la
médaille de la résistance la croix de
guerre et aussi la légion d'honneur
joséphine baker c'est aussi cette tribu
arc en ciel c'est douze enfants adoptés
elle a également résider dans les
yvelines c'est ça que vous reteniez
c'est finalement une femme aux mille
vies on peut le dire comme ça c'est une
femme aux mille vies aux mines aux mille
combat et qui je crois doit nous
inspirer et doit inspirer aussi les plus
jeunes et vous savez que en tant que
femme jeune élu j'ai souvent aussi le
souhait de transmettre aux collégiennes
et lycéennes que elles ne doivent pas se
fixer des limites que tout est possible
qu'elles peuvent saisir pleinement leurs
ambitions et je trouve que le fait
d'amener une classe à cette cérémonie
c'est aussi l'occasion de montrer à ces
jeunes filles qu'elles peuvent
entreprendre dans la vie et qu'il n'y a
pas de plafond de verre qu'il n'y a pas
de porte qui ne s'ouvriront pas si elles
ont le souhait de conduire des projets
et des combats vous serez effectivement
ce soir aux côtés d'une classe de
collégiens que vous accompagnez c'est
d'ailleurs vous qui avez sollicité dans
les bureaux du président de la
république et vous commenciez à en
parler pourquoi justement tout de suite
à avoir fait cette cette démarche il ya
forcément l'éveil à la citoyenneté
derrière mais mais pourquoi ça vous
tenait à coeur d'amener cette classe de
collégiens avec vous ce soir tu t'es
fait alors c'est effectivement l'équipe
éducative qui m'a parlé de ce projet et
on s'est mis tout de suite en contact
avec l'elysée pour rendre possible ce
projet c'est aussi un grand honneur qui
est fait à ces collégiens parce qu'il y
aura très peu de classe qui ceux qui
sont présentés je crois que c'est très
important
elle a vécu dans les yvelines à la
portée des combats je pense que c'est
une femme c'est une femme de couleur
c'est une femme qui a pris la
nationalité française et je pense que
dans tout le parcours de ces jeunes ces
jeunes élèves qui sont amenés à devenir
des futurs citoyens c'était important et
c'est pour ça qu'on a travaillé main
dans la main avec l'équipe éducative de
pouvoir faire aboutir ce projet est de
les emmener à cette cérémonie vous dites
travailler avec l'équipe éducative on
imagine bien que ça a été préparé ce
rendez vous de ce soir un jeudi ce soir
puisqu'on enregistre bien sûr
l'entretien à la mi journée est-ce qu'il
connaissait par exemple joséphine baker
il a fallu peut-être justement préparer
cette venue tout à fait c'est là où il
ya un travail très intéressant qui est
engagée par l'équipe éducative puisque
il y a la volonté il y avait la volonté
de faire connaître aux élèves et puis
aussi de rebaptiser à l'avenir une
classe après classe joséphine baker et
je crois que c'est voilà c'est un beau
symbole aussi quand on arrive à faire
rentrer des hommes et des femmes qui ont
été des lumières pour notre pays au sein
des écoles c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
fait perdurer leur mémoire etc ont fait
valoir leur combat est donc joséphine
baker qui fera son entrée ce soir au
panthéon vous y assister à cette
cérémonie aux côtés je le disais marie
le bec d'une classe de collégiens le
collège sainte-thérèse de houille un qui
est donc sur le territoire de votre
quatrième circonscription des yvelines
merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire à
propos de cette cérémonie qui se tient
encore en ce moment cérémonie de pente
et au nisation de joséphine baker qui
est donc la france lui rend hommage ce
soir un sixième femme à entrer au
panthéon la cérémonie a débuté peu avant
18 heures celle qui fut meneuse de revue
mais aussi résistantes à un temps
résident et on le rappelle au vésinet
elle était née en 1906 dans le missouri
aux états unis elle s'est éteinte en
1975 elle avait pris la nationalité
française en 1937 ce soir la france lui
rend hommage avec cette entrée au
panthéon de joséphine baker
dans l'actualité également c'est à
partir de demain que les adhérents l air
pourront voter pour leurs candidats au
congrès les républicains
celui qui les représentera à l'élection
présidentielle ce lundi eric ciotti
était dans les yvelines eric ciotti
était dans les yvelines le député des
alpes-maritimes a tenu un meeting à
versailles pour présenter son programme
aux adhérents et l'air nicolas landry et
mélanie poquet
il est le quatrième des cinq candidats
congrès les républicains à faire le
déplacement dans les yvelines eric
ciotti est venu présenter ses idées de
mesures pour la présidence une campagne
basée sur les valeurs de la droite être
de droite pour moi c'est à la fois
rétablir l'ordre républicain
c'est choisir qui on veut accueillir
mais c'est aussi je le dis baisser
massivement les impôts qui sont devenus
aujourd'hui insupportable pour beaucoup
de familles france 16 c'est supprimé les
droits de succession c'est baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est tout cela
qui est au coeur de ce projet devancé
par xavier bertrand michel barnier
valérie pécresse et eric ciotti fait
aujourd'hui figure de favori parmi les
élus et anciens élus du territoire
certains sont déjà convaincus d'autres
encore indécis d'abord sur une question
de volonté de faire ce que les gens
annoncent la deuxième chose
j'ai commencé à regarder notre fidélité
en tant que militant depuis aux plus de
50 ans je pense que les gens qui ont
toujours fait partie de notre famille
politique
sont les plus à même de la représenter
j'ai choisi effectivement xavier
bertrand cela étant je tenais à venir
saluer mon ami ciotti parce qu'il défend
avec vigueur nombre de thèmes qui sont
aussi les miens et surtout il le fait
avec une campagne extrêmement assidus et
permanente j'ai l'impression que son
programme n'y a pas grand chose de
différent ce qui va jouer c'est plus la
personnalité est encore une fois
l'envisagent ire de faire le vote des
adhérents des républicains débute ce
mercredi 1er décembre le congrès se
tient le 4 décembre prochain
les organisateurs redoutaient une
annulation au vu du contexte sanitaire
et l'ouverture aussi de la troisième
dose de vaccination en france le grand
prix de vélizy aura bien lieu ce
week-end au vélodrome nationale ce sera
la première compétition sportive depuis
20 mois dans l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise la structure qui avait
été transformée en méga centres de
vaccination en mars 2021 va poursuivre
son activité vaccinale en parallèle le
reportage de michael et demi d'euros le
feu vert a été donné ce mardi 30
novembre vingt mois après le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
de nouveau accueillir une compétition
sportive le septième grand prix de
vélizy sera programmé ce dimanche 5
décembre et réunira 150 sportifs c'est
une fierté c'est de redémarrer de
redémarrer les compétitions de
redémarrer les compétitions hivernales
pour pour les coureurs pour les
organisateurs pour les clubs franciliens
et c'est un signe très positif de 2 que
de pouvoir donc
proposer du cyclisme pour tous après
avoir été transformés en méga centres de
vaccination en mars 2021 l'air centrale
est disponible depuis fin octobre
aujourd'hui plus de 600 vaccination sont
effectués quotidiennement dans les
coursives et non pas au centre de la
structure ce qui permet la cohabitation
vous le voyez derrière moi ce sont les
activités sportives et quotidienne du
vélodrome nationale qui ont repris le
cours de leur existence est en mode
événement donc ce soit un événement
culturel ou un événement sportif on
aménage au module l'art centrale pour
pour la configuration de l'événement en
question donc donc tout peut cohabiter à
l'heure actuelle plusieurs
manifestations sportives sont déjà
programmés pour les prochaines semaines
la structure accueillera notamment des
courses cyclistes régional en janvier
février si la situation sanitaire le
permis
et puisqu'on parle de sport le tirage au
sort des 32e de finale de la coupe de
france de football s'est tenue ce lundi
vers ça et connaît son adversaire ou
presque les joueurs de la cité royale
affronteront les vainqueurs de la
rencontre entre les guadeloupéens de
solidarité scolaire et les bas rhinois
de sarre union ce match en retard de la
8è du 8e tour de la compétition doit se
jouer dimanche prochain en région
parisienne quoi qu'il arrive versailles
affrontera une équipe d'une division
inférieure un ou deux échelons d'écart
coup d'envoi le samedi 18 vous l'avez vu
sur cette animation ou le dimanche 19
décembre la date reste à déterminer et
versailles qui au 8e tour est éliminé
poissy au terme d'un derby des yvelines
très indécis victoire 1-0 avec un but
inscrit à un quart d'heure du terme le
club a disposé également en cette année
de cachan neuilly sur marne et lumbres
dans les tours précédents de cette coupe
de france
religion hier lundi la communauté juive
de saint quentin en yvelines étaient
rassemblés pour fêter l'allumage et de
la deuxième bougie de ranocchia c'était
à montigny le bretonneux particularité
cette année une menorah géante en glace
pour célébrer la fête de la lumière le
reportage de mathilde franco
lundi 29 novembre la communauté juive
s'est rassemblée sur la place estienne
franchois choisel à montigny le
bretonneux pour célébrer ensemble
hanoukka ou autrement dit la fête de la
lumière dans ce sens c'est la fête au
camp nou ka ra nou ka qui veut dire en
fait inauguré il y avait cette branche
dans le champ de l'éditeur mais le but
chandelier à sept branches a brûlé
miraculeusement durant huit jours
aujourd'hui nous allumons ce même champ
donner aux commémorations de ce miracle
de cette furie qui a brûlé durant huit
jours une symbolique forte pour les
fidèles puisque ce miracle a eu lieu
durant la domination des grecs mais il y
a un grand message serre que tous
passent aux entendent obscurité dans un
temps où l'oppression la force brutale
semble l'emporter et qu'est ce qu'il
gagne finalement c'est une une lumière
en réalité le message encore une fois
n'est pas un message limité à la
communauté juive ou limiter un endroit
donné c'est littéralement un message
universel une célébration plein de
musique et de danse pour véhiculer ce
message de paix et de rassemblement
c'est aussi une manifestation d'une
de d'habitants de personnes qui
célèbrent la fête des lumières avec
derrière des messages très positif et
donc je pense que c'est bien d'être
présent avec à leurs côtés cette année
la communauté juive de saint quentin en
yvelines a voulu faire les choses en
grand avec l'organisation d'un spectacle
pyrotechnique et l'installation d'une
menora géante en glace alors ses
sculptures en glace j'ai on a trouvé ça
marrant le symbole un peu la jonction du
feu et de la glace la tradition veut que
l'allumage se passe à la tombée de la
nuit chaque jour une nouvelle bougie
vient s'ajouter à la menora au sein des
foyers
une question avant de vous laisser
connaissez-vous l'eau les eaux logis
c'est le savoir non pas du vent ça c'est
le nologie met de l'huile d'olive
l'yvelinois cécile cros en est une
spécialiste et en plus de produire son
huile d'olive elle fait découvrir son
art lors d'ateliers son portrait par
bixente mayence insisté bad
cécile cros et oléo log c'est une
spécialiste des huiles d'olive habitante
de villennes-sur-seine l'animé ce soir
là un atelier au café ouzou de paris
pour transmettre sa passion qui ravit
c'est un cadeau de mes enfants pour mon
anniversaire j'ai pas si théorique celmo
mais avoir un peu plus de culture lié à
l'huile d'olive et pas seulement être
un simple amateur l'atelier divisé en
trois parties deux premières étapes pour
découvrir l'huile d'olive savoir
reconnaître les différentes odeurs et
saveurs
une fois ces connaissances plus concrète
vient la dernière étape a semblé sa
propre huile d'olive ils ont eu besoin
en fait au préalable de connaître les
différents fruité l'amertume le piquant
les notes qu'on peut avoir en et ils ont
eu besoin de s'entraîner et de connaître
ces différents fruité pour après a
semblé et jg et bien voilà moi j'aime
pas trop l'amertume et piquant gens mais
je met moins de celle ci plus de celle
ci en parallèle à ces ateliers c'est si
l'on possède son oliveraie une vocation
découverte en 2007
c'est vraiment le hasard à 30 ans je
suis allé vivre à barcelone si je
rejoins mon mari qui vivaient là bas et
et on a acheté cette oliveraie un peu
par hasard entre guillemets pour avoir
un pied-à-terre le week-end et puis on
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré aujourd'hui
l'eau les eaux log yvelinoise alterne
entre la catalogne et villennes sur
seine ou l autre poster huile cécile
possède environ 4000 bouteilles de 500
millilitres pour les vendre elle a ses
préférences moi j'aime bien faire les
ventes directes parce que je fait
déguster les huiles et je fais une mini
dégustation une mini initiation à
l'oenologie en même temps et puis les
gens peuvent goûter les différentes
huiles dont condé frites est différent
et peut choisir ensuite au mieux leur
ville elle souhaite faire valoir l'huile
d'olive non comme un ajout de matière
grasse mais plutôt un ajout de saveurs
d'arômes dans un plat crus ou cuits son
petit plus insolites l'huile dans les
desserts dans des fruits des salles de
frites et salade d'orange on peut naître
un beau fruité vert un peu piquant amer
sur un cocktail ou une glace ça ramène
du peps à mais ça ramène du verre et ça
je trouve ça chouette s'étonnant lui le
divan en dessert en plus des marchés de
vilaines triel sur seine ou à cheval les
huiles de cécile sont à la vente sur son
site internet qu va tirer fumades as.com
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité dans un instant vous
retrouvez un nouveau numéro du 7-8
culture présentée par célia gars tsongo
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
on